i'm ashley webster i'm kennedy i'm jason
chaffetz and this is the fox news
rundown
friday november 5th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal our tuesday's election results
in part of backlash to years of
discussion about race unfortunately if
you prioritize things like our our past
you really aren't prioritizing at the
same time you know our present or our
future even some democrats agree some
discussions surrounding race may have
gone too far it also shows a lack of
understanding of what the first
amendment is about and i think that we
have a big problem with that and there's
even a problem with that on the right
i'm dave anthony
this weekend we fall back but there is a
move in congress to stop doing that to
save daylight time permanently i think
people are just kind of tired of
needlessly resetting their clocks it's
hard on school kids it's disruptive to
the workforce it's unnecessary
and ask the question why is it
preferable to have it get dark at 5 pm
and i'm joe mackey i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
one of the big debates in virginia ahead
of tuesday's election for governor was
about education and parental involvement
in school but also crt critical race
theory and discussions about how race is
being applied to school curriculums
specifically in history classes the
republican candidate for governor glenn
younkin seized on this topic we will not
have political agendas in the classroom
and i will ban critical race theory
the democrat in the race terry mcauliffe
said we do not teach critical race
theory here in virginia it has never
been taught it is a racist dog whistle
junkin the republican went on to win and
so did the republican lieutenant
governor republican attorney general and
the house of delegates flipped to
republican in a state that had been
trending blue for the past decade new
jersey's incumbent governor democrat
phil murphy won but by a much closer
margin than expected after that there
were mixed headlines and individual
reaction about democrats that they were
in panic mode reverend al sharpton said
we've got to really bring everybody
together and understand that this is a
wake-up call on the flip side of that
president obama's former advisor david
plouffe said critical race theory is a
lie and i think we have to go on offense
the former office of management and
budget director russ vogt now the
founder of the center for renewing
america told fox news anchor john
roberts on thursday well they're at a
crossroads i mean how can you say that
it doesn't exist and then you have
others who are saying it's time to
double down on it that the way to deal
with this is to go on offense and what
we saw in virginia is we saw parents
rejecting that across the state and
being able to say we are going to get
this out of our schools and you're not
going to call us a racist ahead of the
election i talked to mary margaret
casselberg a republican who lost her bid
for a delegate seat but said in her
conversations with people knocking on
doors she found a deeper issue here then
this is the overall environment of
people feeling like they can't speak
freely
without fear of retribution which is
terrible you know that's a that's not
the country that we are that kind of
feeling may have been brewing for some
time people at this point that are being
placated like the outrage mob
they're the same people on social media
that they were before they were social
media they're losers jimmy fayla is a
comedian and host of fox news talks fox
across america the reason the outrage
mob is starting to lose culture wars is
we now understand who they are they're
people who want to make everything about
them they're people that ruin otherwise
good times because they want to create
some type of slight in which they're now
owed some type of emotional or tangible
reparation you know you know a person
like some people do this as a joke but
you've seen people do this seriously
where you say to them out like you look
nice today and they go today
like i don't look nice other days
yes
and it's like we do that to each other
as a joke once in a while but we've all
met a person who does that and it's not
like shtick it's like oh no no they're
actually like they can't just take the
compliment and you're like oh i get it
you're a crazy person and that's why
they're losing their power i think is
because we realize who they are now when
i was in virginia jimmy um ahead of the
election i was talking to you know a lot
of doing the man on the street thing and
talking to a lot of people and
you know one of the big through lines
and narratives ahead of that race was
about education
and a subset of that was about critical
race theory right like is it being
taught is it not what are teachers being
trained in
and what are kids learning and through
what lens right and some people did
express concern
said it's going too far
but others said it is time to be
more sensitive to shift to be more
inclusive recognize diversity in the
classroom maybe half your class is of a
different ethnicity and it's time to
acknowledge that when comedians walk
into a room and they have a an
incredibly diverse room on you know on
many occasions
what line do you walk what line do you
feel you have to walk if any none and
here's the reason why when you make fun
of somebody in a comedy club you're
treating them as an equal to everyone
else in the room you're not
infantilizing them and putting them in
the off-limits section like oh these
just these poor people because that's
what you're doing if someone can't be
made fun of you're saying they are a
protected class of person they are not
equal to the people you're okay with
laughing at so when i'm in a club i mean
i'm not that i'm going out of my way i'm
not like a shock jock per se
uh but i am out there trying to make
sure that everybody who goes to a comedy
club and pays for two watered down
overpriced drinks gets the same
treatment in that room you know you
don't want an off-limits section but
that is kind of what we are creating and
to something you said earlier um i am
offended that you said it's a man on the
street i consider it a they on the
street uh i don't see gender it's just a
you know it's a fluid thing uh but no i
get it and you know back to the point of
what kids really quickly about the
classroom here's the thing i have a 12
year old kid we are um
we're dumping this on them they don't go
out there and
predicate people's worth to society
based on their racial identity they
predicated based on who's cool and not
cool who will share their toys you know
who will give you an extra cookie at
lunch they are not out there living in a
world where we're judging people by the
color of their skin most of us i think
in society like 99 of us are doing the
martin luther king thing judging by the
content of their character not the color
of their skin and where i think the
issue comes with critical race theory is
they're presenting this as if
we don't want to teach america's real
history when in truth nobody in the
history of this country has taken a
social studies class that didn't say we
had institutional slavery okay the
problem with critical race theory is not
that it's teaching our hit our history
it's that it continues to claim that
it's our present it's saying we've never
made the progress that we made and i
think a lot of people are so insulted by
that claim because it really denigrates
the contributions of all the people who
fought and died in protest and got beat
up and went to jail for civil rights
it's like nobody is saying we're a
perfect country but we're not going to
get there if we can't acknowledge how
much progress we've made to get here
finally jimmy i was reading on twitter i
even heard
some talk show hosts while i was in
virginia and you know there have even
been some op-eds after tuesday with what
happened in virginia and how close it
was in new jersey that really the
republican sort of victory in virginia
and the closeness in jersey was
in part a rejection
of some of this stuff that we've been
talking about some of this you know um
that people don't want to have these
cultural issues um and feel like they're
being labeled a certain way um and we've
already talked about race and how it's
you know being taught um how big a role
do you think
that that cultural discussion
um played in in tuesday's elections i
think if you look at the exit polls it
was a big role and that's my gut too in
just being on talk radio every day it's
not that people are against teaching us
about race it's not that people are
against teaching our history it's that
doing so doesn't offer a deliverable to
people that are struggling right now
like if you can't pay your bills you
can't afford a tank of gas ripping down
the thomas jefferson statue doesn't help
i'm not saying you know you're not
entitled to that view whether you want
to rip a statue down put a plaque up i'm
not saying you're not entitled to teach
america's history but the problems
facing people right now are substantive
primal problems and they're not problems
um you know that come from the
superficial space of how we discuss
issues it's from the space of the house
is on fire can we get a hose and some
water and unfortunately if you
prioritize things like our our past you
really aren't prioritizing at the same
time you know our present or our future
and that's where i think people in
virginia rejected this on such a large
scale and made education probably the
central issue is because they realize
yes it's important
but it's not important to re-segregate
society through racial identity and
that's what a lot of people felt was
going on and lastly i don't know who the
political strategist was who told terry
mcauliffe he should tell parents to shut
up but in my experience telling suburban
women to shut up doesn't generally end
as good as you might think it would now
depending on which democrats you talk to
after virginia's election they are
experiencing mixed feelings about this
discussion jessica tarlov a fox news
contributor and democratic strategist
thinks it's not as dominant as some
think though still something the party
has to grapple with well it was
certainly a through line uh in virginia
in new jersey i don't think it was a
factor whatsoever i don't i don't think
that crt a critical race theory came up
uh whatsoever in debates or in any
conversation that phil murphy had uh
definitely more of an issue in virginia
but it was really interesting if you
look at the op-ed that glenn younkin the
governor-elect wrote for us on
foxnews.com he didn't mention critical
race theory in it he talked about
education
in general and he talked about parents
having good services right that public
schools should work for them and
problems with the teachers unions and i
think that that was more of the
pervasive problem than the culture war
issues and that's how you got so many
people who had supported democrats in
past elections uh whether voting for
president biden or voting for ralph
northam for instance uh to switch over
and to support glenn youngken so i saw
it more as education than the culture
war side of education
but no doubt it it was a factor for some
and when you look at how many uh trump
voters young kim was able to turn out in
rural areas he actually did better than
the former president did you know that
the culture war stuff was resonating
there a great video was sent to me of
comedians talking about how they feel
like they can't go on college campuses
specifically anymore that everyone's
just offended and it's it's antithetical
to comedy and i think it was john cleese
who had some really insightful
commentary a few years ago about how
when you're surrounded by people who are
like just so super sensitive you can't
be free
and that political correctness has
turned into like
any joking criticism of any group ends
up being labeled cruel
where do
where does the democratic party go with
this word is the progressive wing
of the democratic party go with this
especially when you hear comedians
talking about
college campuses it's the it's younger
folks in particular right i mean they're
going to grow up and
we're you know all the older folks
aren't going to be here anymore so
they're they're the ones who are going
to be in power these people on
university campuses who
you know are particularly sensitive the
backlash on campuses um against
thought from the other side has been a
big problem on someone who
was in academia for a long time through
my phd level i certainly know what these
campuses are like
and i think that
it was something positive about joe
biden that people felt
like he got it that he was a normal
person right who made mistakes and had
friends of other political persuasions
and it was like a return to normalcy
that way
and i think with the
the way that the democratic party is
structured right now we we don't have
progressives
in huge positions of power like nancy
pelosi whipped clyburn uh steny hoyer
etc those are all you know tried and
true moderates um but it will be
something that needs to be addressed and
and an art form like comedy does need to
be stood up for you know i'm not
necessarily taking sides on the dave
chappelle
versus transgender netflix employees
debate um even though i'm a huge
chappelle fan and i'm glad that he said
that he would meet with whoever but also
i'm not taking my jokes down um
it's a bummer because
first of all you miss out on a lot of
of great fun
in not partaking in the comedy that
these people are producing um but it
also shows a lack of understanding of
what the first amendment is about and i
think that we have a big problem with
that and there's even a problem with
that on the right if you look at josh
hawley who was going to sue simon
schuster i think was his publisher right
they said that they didn't want to
publish his book anymore after he
participated
in the january 6 demonstrations
and
um
you know he said like this is orwellian
it's not orwellian right it's free press
right it's free market capitalism they
made a decision as a private company
that they didn't want to publish his
book he then went and got picked up
somewhere else so this isn't something
that only the left does it's something
that the right runs with as well um and
they don't want to own up to that which
i think is extremely detrimental to the
conversation but i guess if i could you
know
if i could get away with it i probably
would continue to try to as well
jessica tarlov thanks so much for your
time thank you
[Music]
this is joe mackey with your fox news
commentary coming up
we fall back this weekend reverting to
standard time giving most of us an extra
hour of sleep though when we wake up
sunday we will have to change the clocks
in a digital world not really a big deal
anymore but some people
have had enough i don't like the
the changing time at all because it kind
of messes me up
it messes everybody's up many want to
stop falling back to just spring forward
and leave the clock that way i guess we
get the extra hour of
daylight so i'll take it many lawmakers
agree nearly 20 states have passed laws
or resolutions for permanent daylight
saving time
but congress won't allow that it only
lets states opt for permanent standard
time which arizona and hawaii have they
don't change the clocks there
congressman chris stewart is trying to
change all this with a proposed federal
daylight savings act it's not a partisan
issue there's bipartisan support for
this effort it's not a red state blue
state issue congressman stewart is a
republican from utah my gosh california
supports it florida alabama washington i
mean it's a mix of interest here again
because it affects every american
and i think people are just kind of
tired of needlessly resetting their
clocks it's hard on school kids it's
disruptive to the workforce it's
unnecessary and ask the question why is
it preferable to have it get dark at 5
pm when i was in the air force we were
stationed at a northern tier base and
our kids were walking home from school
in the dark and i just think there's a
lot of people who feel like hey let's
just leave it on daylight savings time
let's not have the change let's have
that extra hour in the evening rather
than in the early morning and we hope
we're going to be able to get this done
okay so let's let's
go through where we are now
at the moment this is something that
states
decide
in the current system a state can choose
whether to have daylight saving time or
not have any at all like arizona and
hawaii they never change the clocks but
they're on they're on standard time all
the time if a state wants to change to
standard time it can if it wants to
change permanently to daylight saving
time
what happens
it it cannot right now as you said
states are currently unable to opt out
of the standard time and we want to give
them that option of staying on the
daylight savings time uh which is it's
you know it's confusing for some people
they may not know because we only
consider you know once or twice a year
but daylight savings time is the time
we're on now and right now states have
to switch back to standard time and
we're just want to give them the option
and look we recognize it would be
disruptive if one or two states did it
but we don't think only one or two
states will again we've got 19 or 20
states who've indicated already that
they would follow this and we have many
more that indicate hey if that's allowed
us as a possibility we certainly would
and and they would do it in regions as
well and i think that's kind of the key
to this is there's got to be some
consistencies but we think there's
enough states who have indicated that
this would be their interest to do that
that we would have that i i do think the
last last point is that it should be up
to states i don't know that the federal
government should mandate the time for
states and again recognizing regional
interest but also recognizing that many
states have already indicated that they
would do it on a regional basis we
really do think it's kind of a win-win
okay so what would you have congress do
what rules would you want in place if
this was something you could get passed
what would you do
we would just allow states to choose to
stay on daylight savings time rather
than be compelled to go to standard time
and it's really that simple now you
mentioned region would you have to do it
with other states in your area or could
you do by yourself as a state well
you technically could do it by yourself
but as we've already indicated we know
that there's a majority of states who
would like to do it and that we would
anticipate they would do it by region
okay uh so i think you may have a couple
one-offs for example arizona is slightly
different than the other states around
right now so we wouldn't compel them
but
i think there's clear advantage in this
as i said we've got 19 states already
who have who have passed legislation to
do it we've got many more who've said if
and given the opportunity we would do it
so we don't think that the one ops is
going to be a problem we think we have
the vast majority states and probably
all the states would choose to do this
would it be confusing though if let's
say 33 states decided to do it the other
17 decided not to make it permanent and
then some you know some either stayed
standard like arizona and hawaii or
others do the time switch i mean
would it be hard to know where what
state if you're doing business what
state did it and what state didn't what
time it is or is it that really not that
big an issue
well i mean that would be the worst case
outcome but again we don't think that
that will happen but we don't think it's
going to be
the problem that some people propose it
might be okay now you mentioned this is
bipartisan people on the right and left
like this people in different states red
states and blue states like this
so
why can't it get done how many lawmakers
have you spoken to that oppose allowing
states to make a decision like this
well so far to answer that question is
none
and
and i and i mean that literally i mean
there's no one that we've reached out to
who hasn't said yeah we would support
that now there's been a few have said
hey let me let me talk to my state
legislators let me talk to my state
leaders make sure that this would
reflect what they would want to do so
there have been a few have said let me
get back to you but no one has said no i
don't think we want to do that
and you know it's interesting to the
diverse backgrounds of people who
support this i come from a farming
background so every fall my brothers
call me who are still running the family
farm and they say hey when are you going
to change this law so we don't have to
switch our times again i've talked to
nurses i've talked to school teachers
i've talked to young families i mean
very very diverse backgrounds and i
think that's reflected in our response
in congress when we talk to other
congressional members i think they they
reflect those varied interests and and
that's why it's been able to be
bipartisan and again not a red state
blue state thing across the country so
if that's the case and you have all this
support how do you get it passed how do
you get the bill on in on the floor of
congress get it in the senate i mean why
what's taking so long what would be
what's the obstacle
oh my gosh if you're an impatient person
please don't run for congress
uh
it just takes time and part of it is
just getting people's attention which is
what we're doing now we're getting
building our our co-sponsors and you
know we i i think we're gonna have a
couple hundred co-sponsors on this and
after that you have to get floor time
and as you know the congress has been
very very busy uh doing some some bills
that frankly i think make no sense at
all but that's uh that's what ms flossie
has chosen to do so it's really just
kind of a matter of working through the
process but if i could give you an
analogy that maybe cast some light on
this i've sponsored a bill to create a
national suicide prevention hotline
number 988
bipartisan it's going to literally save
thousands of lives it doesn't cost any
money
and oh my gosh who doesn't want to help
someone who's in the middle of a mental
health crisis right or someone who who
suicide prevention
that bill as easy as it was and as
important was still took three years and
i use that as example even the easy
things take to take time in congress so
we're not surprised that this one's the
same but you know we're going to keep at
it and we think that we've got a
momentum to where we're going to be able
to get it done hopefully get it done in
the next year so okay
let me give you
the opposition side to having full-time
daylight saving time and that generally
goes into
if you go and you
are on saving time permanently
as we get into november here we are and
then december a month from now
i'll use logan utah you were born there
correct congressman yep that's right
logan utah has a sunrise
on december 20 which is right around the
longest day of the year
of 7 51 a.m in standard time
if it was permanently daylight saving
time the sun would rise at 8 51 in the
morning and the argument is that all the
kids who go to school in logan utah will
be waiting for the bus in the dark
and that's one of the concerns that
people will be driving to work in the
dark and all the commute in the dark so
that's the concern about having
permanent daylight saving time what's
your response
well
i mean a couple things one is i wish we
could pass legislation that would give
us 14 hours of sunlight every day that
would be ideal but not able to chew that
one and so then you have the trade-offs
and i think the question is would you
rather have that hour of sunlight in the
in the afternoon or in in the early
morning and i really think that most
people would prefer it in the afternoon
and so you use your example well kids
are waiting at the school bus in the
dark or the semi-dark right uh but but
as i've already indicated uh having been
stationed up north and other things i
mean our kids were walking home in the
dark so it's not uh you don't eliminate
that problem it's either in the
beginning of the day or at the end of
the day well most kids don't go to most
kids don't go home from school at 4 45
unless they have an after-school
activity schools do get out in most
places between two and four o'clock when
even in even in standard times worst
horrible darkness times in the afternoon
it's still light
well i mean i think that kind of depends
number one is a lot of kids are involved
with school activities and you know the
school day kind of fluctuates from
depending on where you are of course in
your local school district
uh but it but it wasn't uncommon at all
and and i think you could also count
argue well a lot of schools don't start
at you know eight or seven fifty a lot
of schools start at you know eight
thirty or quarter to nine
uh but but but you're right i mean this
doesn't solve that problem it just makes
it so we transferred that to the
afternoon but but again a lot of people
i think feel that as we've as we've
talked to people a lot of people think
that hey that's my preference the other
thing is it eliminates this changing of
time so
it allows people to kind of get on one
time stay on that time you adjust to the
daylight you know whether it's in the
morning uh or later on the afternoon
allows you to for the consistency and
that's one of the benefits to the
building i think a hundred years ago
when we really were a rural
uh you know an agricultural standard
economy and centered people
which was i think one of the main points
you know people were used to getting up
with the sun they were used to going out
and milking the cows and you know taking
care of the garden and that kind of
thing earlier and then you know you know
being tired and
and kind of relaxing or drying things
down in the evening but
our culture just isn't like that any
longer i mean so much of our activity so
much of things we do now are after
school events or you know we don't go
home to work from work at three o'clock
in the afternoon so
i mean myself my personal preference
would be to give me that sunlight in the
afternoon not nearly morning okay so you
think that maybe by let's let's all
right you said i should be patient
let's say it's uh one year from now
2022 and we're getting ready to to fall
back again do you think congress by then
will have passed this law
i think it's 50 50 or maybe a little
more and it's hard for me to predict
because um
as i said i don't i'm a republican i'm
not the majority so we don't get control
of the house floor but i think that
we're going to get enough democratic
support for this that we can get some of
their attention so
um again i hate to do predictions
especially in politics oh my gosh i can
imagine that uh but you know i'm i'm
hopeful and i'm i'm realistically
hopeful that we can republican
congressman chris stewart from utah
thank you very much for joining us well
it's been fun thank you so much
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts rate and
review the fox news rundown on apple
podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
nothing brings on the nostalgia like
seeing a toy you had when you were a
child
they can be good memories like getting
your first barbie or your favorite hot
wheels car or they can be memories that
spark other feelings
like the easy bake oven you never got
either way toys hold a special place in
our hearts and this year's class of
playthings inducted into the national
toy hall of fame may have a few memories
bubbling up for you the newest inductees
are american girl dolls the strategy
board game risk and sand
they were chosen from 12 finalists which
included four other games like
battleship and billiards as well as
cabbage patch kids masters of the
universe fisher-price corn popper the
toy fire engine and the pinata
the toy hall of fame is in the strong
national museum of play in rochester new
york anyone can nominate a toy but to be
considered they must have withstood the
test of time and memory changed play or
toy design and fostered learning
creativity or discovery hence the
induction of sand this year which the
group called perhaps the most universal
and oldest toy in the world
this year's inductees joined 74 previous
honorees including the big wheel the
game of life gi joe crayola crayons and
the easy bake oven
always wanted one of those with a little
light inside the little k i'm over it
i'm i'm really i'm really past it y'all
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
joe mackey
what's on your mind a lot of people
wonder what it's like being a stand-up
comedian during a pandemic well the
rooms are half full the club owners look
disappointed and people call me a
murderer so not much has changed except
that when they say murderer now it's not
a euphemism for having a great set they
actually think i'm a murderer
that brings up a challenge that's been
increasing long before the coronavirus
was probably created in a lab there's a
massive shortage in critical thinking am
i really a murderer for performing
stand-up comedy each club i worked at
has been abiding by local covent rules
basically a comedy club's like a
restaurant so i went to a restaurant and
i talked if i'm a murderer it's because
of something else and you can't prove
anything
there's a critical shortage of critical
thinking i've heard people inside
restaurants without masks eating
complain when people walk in without a
mask
so people not wearing masks or
complaining about others not wearing
masks the explanation is they're allowed
to remove their mask while they're
eating as if kovid cares they just
aren't thinking they're just following
the rules from the experts that have a
worse track record than a derailed train
i better be careful talking about
unimproved realities can get you
censored i should just go along with the
mainstream speaking of which have you
heard my new joke about how women like
shopping
i'm joe mackey head to joemackie.com
m-a-c-h-i to find out where you can
catch my stand-up
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
[Music]